it's going everybody this hectare here
from Lords of gaming net here job from
dirty beast gaming here talk about the
game right here feral fronts here
how you doing say Josh hey how's it
going good good so Tesla by feral
frontier feral frontier is a 2d
side-scroller kind of nostalgic retro
feeling action platformer it's got some
minor RPG elements but we really just
take all the good stuff that we loved
growing up and tried to fit it into a
game and hopefully not feel too
convoluted in the process
perfect perfect ends like it sound like
a dream game for the people of the
saundra and looking to get into it maybe
be the monster on his first game me
about the plat action platformer it
sounds great so tell us a little about
the character yeah I hear it's like your
mascot for fair frontier what's going on
yeah Reynard the Fox he's kind of his
name is based on a lot of the old fables
and fairy tales and he's kind of a
trickster character I always had a was
partial to him ever since I was playing
tails and sonic you know and I guess I
just felt like he had that kind of like
quick movement to him that really helped
with feeling like the kind of Mega Man X
gameplay that we're kind of going for in
the moment-to-moment not entirely we mix
it up but that kind of turn on a dime
wall jumping sliding on walls and just
being like responsive we were going for
that so I felt like that character fit
it but as far as his story goes we're
thinking that we're still kind of trying
to make sure the game comes first before
the narrative dictates on top of that we
want the narrative kind of support the
game so the rough idea at this point
because it's not figured out entirely is
he's kind of actually just grown up his
whole life in captivity so he doesn't
even know what it means to be like wild
and so he's kind of actually escaped and
he's discovering like the wilderness as
it is and seen for the first time the
laws of nature and the kind of dangers
of the world and kind of learning what
it means to be a fox that's the
character goblin also most of it sounds
it sounds like a great premise so let's
have some gameplay here he braked a
little bit with the levels that people
would be playing sure yeah so for this
is just a kind of display demo so though
the whole thing is really linear and
it's designed in such a way that it's
like a tutorial the actual game
is much more nonlinear we're trying to
like kind of strike a balance between
like Super Metroid
and Super Mario World so there's an
overworld map with actual isolated
levels but those isolated levels have
like fast travel checkpoints in them
that you can drop in and out at any time
anywhere and so you can kind of
backtrack quickly and kind of move
around in a nonlinear fashion you don't
have to beat a level you can go in play
a bit pop out of it jump to another
level and kind of play in a nonlinear
way so speedrunners are gonna find all
kinds of I mean this is gonna definitely
be a speedrun or a friendly game because
he has so many moves that you're gonna
be able to do things that we didn't
anticipate and you're gonna master I'm
making a be your own style I'm a just a
big Smash Bros fan so we wanted it to
feel like you had all these choices
gonna have your style and one of the big
elements of how he plays is he has the
kind of rock-paper-scissors of a
fighting game he can block grab and
attack and those are don't just they
don't just function in combat but they
also gonna help with puzzle solving and
platforming exploration stuff we wanted
everything to kind of cover all those
bases so it's not just a one one core
purpose movie you know yeah you look you
have a lot of options here I'm seeing on
the screen right now it looks like looks
looks gonna be a very diverse game very
fun kind of game to approach they
definitely have different people gonna
have different approaches that are gonna
be unique and you're gonna see things
I'm sure that people are gonna break it
in crazy ways and they'll always happen
but I'd like to think that most like you
know most players who get really into it
they'll have their own style and it will
look different because we implemented a
skill system to kind of customize your
character and by doing that you could
literally have a different loadout and
be capable of different things and so
the kind of gates that we put in the
game aren't so strict like this requires
the super missile like in Super Metroid
it's it's not like that's more softbox
it's like this thing is just really high
up there
so either you put a lot into stamina and
you have the climb ability you can go up
or you've mastered the pivot jump and
the double jump and you can there's also
there's many ways actually to get jumps
in this game you can down it you can
down aerial attack with a melee attack
off a heads which is like a lot of games
yeah
it's like you did looks like you're
doing a laugh over here yeah yeah that's
perfect well could tell us what or a
fair frontier is gonna be played on what
platforms are you gonna put it on well
first we're gonna drop on Steam we don't
have a release date yet we're wish-list
able but basically PC first just out of
these is our first real major game
everything else was kind of it just uh
like a practice off to perfect perfect
wouldn't you plan to release it I think
realistically within the next two years
it's just because we have day jobs I'm a
carpenter by day and I go home and with
a Leonard Energy I have left this is
what I do so perfect perfect well it's
is looking sorry but we'd love to be on
consoles like because it's meant to be
played with a controller so we will
target that eventually perfect pervy
well it's looking amazing so far thank
you so much for taking the time to talk
to us thank you and good luck building
development is it's hecka from Lords of
gaming I'll catch you guys later